[Music]
over the past few years the custom
gaming peripheral market has absolutely
popped off from mice to custom
mechanical keyboards artisan mouse pads
and even chairs you can pretty much do
whatever you want with your setup some
learn how to do the job themselves while
others seek the help of professionals
but among gaming's top peripheral
weaponsmiths is a guy named nacho
customs nacho spent the past few years
making a name for himself by doing
custom paint jobs for some of your
favorite streamers pro players and even
manufacturers here's how he does it this
is the regular and then this is what he
painted how sick is that
[Applause]
alright so before he started customizing
mice for people like shroud where
exactly did the gaming world's go-to
designer come from well born and raised
in uruguay nacho moved to miami when he
was 10 years old and like most of us it
didn't take long for him to get hooked
on gaming
gaming just ever since i was a kid to be
honest with you um you know playstation
everything that would come by the house
um back in uh you know um it's a little
harder over there to have access to all
these consoles and stuff
um so we would you know pay and then go
play at like an arcade as he grew older
nacho became obsessed with painting his
shoes computers and mice with various
anime inspired designs but when he made
a post on the mouse review subreddit
back in 2019 that's when he really
started to blow up
people from there just started you know
how much would you charge you know it
did work for me or whatnot
before i realized you know i had like
let's say 10 orders lined up in my first
month and i was like okay cool that was
interesting
from then on nacho began doing more and
more research in order to learn how to
disassemble each and every type of mouse
videos from youtubers like bearded bob
helped him learn all the ins and outs of
the gaming peripherals while channels
like paint society helped teach him how
to paint the products without causing
any damage once he got more practice in
and he started posting more of his work
online nacho eventually caught the eye
of a fortnite pro named kuna who he
commissioned a mouse for in may 2020.
nacho took advantage of his newfound
exposure and began sharing content to
his youtube channel in order to help
others customize their own peripherals
and if you're a mousehead like me then
you won't be surprised that his videos
on the g pro and razer viper ultimate
just blew up because he uses a high
quality clear coat the paint doesn't
wear off the mouse which makes his
services way more desirable by march
2021 nacho was fulfilling enough orders
to make his hobby a full-time job so he
left his role as an analyst at a
healthcare company i did have a couple
of pros from apex reach out and you know
once i did one for hal which was like
the first apex bro to reach out to me
everybody else just you know came along
after since then nacho has painted mice
for pokemane nadeshot and basically
everyone from offline tv and because of
his success in the business he recently
relocated to la he's become the goad of
custom peripherals for plenty of
streamers and competitors and it's given
him the opportunity to connect with some
of his favorite creators because you see
like most of us
nacho kinda heckin loves tens
i didn't know tense personally um but i
went into this chat when it was one of
those days and uh i gifted him five subs
um it was just you know me being a
casual just watching and stuff and then
i don't know where he's like oh nacho
you know thanks for the subs whatever
he's like i've seen you do a custom
mouse that's really cool and i'm like oh
i didn't know he knew who i was so that
was nice and then i got to meet him at
final con and everything so it's it's
really something surreal to be honest
with you
now if you're like many of us at the
office and you're a peripheral head then
you'll know that in the world of decking
out your setups there are many people
like nacho hell just last year we did a
video on teja types a bespoke keyboard
builder who has put together commissions
for some of the biggest streamers and
pros in the world but this trend it
doesn't exactly end at keyboard and mice
you can find artists willing to
customize practically any part of your
setup there are people out there who
even specialize in [ __ ] cables now if
you're just a pleb like me and you want
nacho to make you a custom valorant or
star wars themed super light then what
should you do well first off you should
check out his site there you'll find
anime inspired mouse pads peripheral
accessories and most importantly his
order form
so i have a order form on my website at
the moment um which is what i encourage
most people to go through first which
pretty much uh before you enter any
information about yourself you get to
pretty much tell me you know what mouse
you want um what kind of paint job so
like you know single color multi-color
if you want like an rgb logo on it if
you want to also paint the dock and
stuff like that
um pretty much you could place the order
through there um obviously you know
reach out to me privately if you have
any questions or whatnot and i also give
the option to the client you know send
their own mouse if they don't want to
buy a new one because i know that's
pricey and i mean you don't necessarily
need to if you already have one
um or you know they could just buy a new
one through my website i'll just order
from amazon and you know we go from
there now that nacho has become one of
the most popular custom mice designers
in the entire industry he's at the point
where he wants to branch out i'm trying
to uh you know trying to expand some
more things you know like keyboards
computer cases and stuff like that
grateful for you know all the pros that
have given me like an opportunity to get
it started and you know put my name out
there
thanks to his recent work with streamers
like shroud who he painted a dope iron
man themed mouse for nacho has earned a
lot of clout within the community
although he started out as just some guy
posting his work to reddit nacho is now
one of the most sought after artists in
the entire gaming space
foreign